Hãy xem thường trị Trung Quốc tại linh của ông Phong Thông,
dài thích lý gió bắt kinh bỏ vưu trắng đối với sự thẳng hịt của đồng và ăn với Trung đông.
Ông cho biết, Trung Quốc quan trảy tình díng lếu thang yang chẳng tại của bực lịch bà từ,
đặc biệt khi các khu tấn công quân sự của Mỹ và Israel diễn ra,
trong dưới đoạn đảm phản sông phương Vy Van, ông khẳng định,
điều này gió sang Vy Van có mũ đích và nguyên tác của hiểm chương linh của ông và kéo tính chính đáng.
Ông Phong Thông cũng nhận mạnh lịch sự trong đồng cho thấy,
bố lực không phải giải pháp, cây đồng quân sự chỉ làm giá tăng mùi cơ không hoàn và đầy khu vực này vào bé tát.
Đồng thời bàn to ở Trung Quốc có trậm dự thẳng định của Israel và Iran,
và các đầy xuất ưu tiến đối thoại bình đàn của bắt kinh cho đường xem xế thoại đáng.
Vy Van nước này không còn lựa trọn nào khác ngoài việc bỏ vưu trắng.
Ông Phong thông nhận mạnh xa phép lâu xài là trậm dân này có họ đậm quân sự,
ngân trạng lếu thang tiếp theo và quay trở lại đối thoại bình đàn.
Chúng cô hẳng định sẽ tư tổng thật tác về cái nước Trung Quốc vực và cậm đồng của tế,
nhằm thuộc đầy hoa bình bầu định tại Trung đâm.
Chúng cô và ngàn là hai của Sơn Suy nhất bỏ phíau trắng và nghị quế liên quân đến tỉnh Trung đâm của Hội Đồng Bà Lil Quốc.
Kêu gọi Iran chăm zâm ngày lập tất cả của tấn công nhằm và cơ cơ xa vùng vệ.
Nhi quế đã đưa thông qua với huy bà phía thuật.